je vous le disais au début de cette
édition jean marc ayrault qui s'est
engagé aujourd'hui à la réalisation
intégrale du futur métro automatique
grand paris express d'ici à 2030 nous
avons en ligne à nouveau robert
cadalbert président ps de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines
robert cadalbert nous avons coupé la
communication tout à l'heure avec vous
qui était un petit peu compliqué elle
nous parlions du de la réalisation qui
se fera de ce grand paris express
d'ailleurs on parle maintenant de
nouveau grand paris c'est le nom du
nouveau projet la ligne verte qui
concerne saint quentin en yvelines va
voir le jour
en revanche on sera sur un mode de
transport plus légers cette fois ci ce
sera adapté aux besoins de transport
c'est une adaptation pour faire quelques
économies d'ailleurs c'est ce qu'on a
toujours demandé avec le maire de
guyancourt je la vois un métro j'ai le
niveau du calendrier on parle d'une
réalisation en 2030 livraison 2030 pour
cette partie qui intéresse saint quentin
en yvelines est les travaux auraient
lieu plus tôt vers 2020 2025
c'est pas trop tard à la fois on à l'ars
exactions que ce transport en commun de
la easy jet au club vert et on va avoir
une accusation du transport en commun en
site propre fallait que 50 années et a
fait 15 ans que l'on met on arrive à
notre enfant comment s'y prête sur la
ville nouvelle pour des buses et les
gens que lui ça ne rapporte que la
technologie que soit métro léger les
trop doux amer bus pour le transport
enfin on aura l'assurance que je prend
froid comme en fait preuve lui un conte
en pyjama
je fasse rapidement dans les cinq ans
qui il va falloir le financer aussi sur
les différentes pistes évoquées
éventuellement une aide demandée aux
collectivités est ce que ça veut dire
que ça coûtera plus cher aux habitants
de saint quentin en yvelines par exemple
et puis bien sûr par l'état et par
l'impôt sur les entreprises se trouvant
tu fais que te matraquage et fait
l'entreprise qui a été créée par la loi
sarkozy
sur le grand paris soit physiquement
modifié afin que les continue et ça
permettra de développer véritablement
aussi saint quentin et le plateau de
saclay la dynamique est bonne la
dynamique est lancée mais fallu que faim
quant à lui le plateau de saclay je fais
que le répéter fait toute la partie
occidentale du plateau frac la corde
donc on peut pas parler et du plateau de
saclay 50 avec que tu fais la même chose
et donc ce développement est assuré pour
ce pôle cette entité à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines saclay
aujourd'hui vous repartez vous repartez
de demain en aval et vous repartez de
seine et marne avec des assurances à
toute question très importante ce qu'on
a toujours défendu avec le verre de lui
encore seulement ce transport en commun
soit disant là là là mais aussi
l'amélioration des transports en commun
étant et jean marc ayrault le premier et
avec le fondateur de l'opération des
transports merci robert cadalbert
d'avoir été en ligne avec nous un pour
ses réactions alors que vous repartez
toujours tout juste de seine-et-marne
vous étiez avec le premier ministre
jean-marc ayrault pour évoquer la
création de ce grand paris express le
nouveau grand paris c'est le nom qui a
été donné à ce projet qui est donc
officialisée le financement est assuré
d'ici à 2030 les réalisations seront
toutes opérationnelles jean marc ayrault
l'a dit 2030 c'est la date de fin et de
travaux trop tard disent les élus de
l'ump ils sont une cinquantaine
d'ailleurs dans le département des
yvelines à avoir interpellé le premier
ministre via un courrier il ya quelques
jours parmi eux sophie primas sénatrice
ump de la 9e circonscription 2030 c'est
trop loin tout retard qui est pris
aujourd'hui un retard sur la
compétitivité est un retard sur
l'attractivité de notre capitale est
encore une fois de la france en entier
pour valérie pécresse est très actif
comme vous le savez sur ce dossier là
évidemment en tant que leader de
l'opposition dans la région elle très
active aussi puisqu'elle à notre chef de
file dans les yvelines
elle a été
la pointe de ce projet sur saclay elle
donc pas prêts nous ne sommes pas prêts
de lâcher la contestation si jamais une
partie de ce projet devait ne pas voir
le jour grand paris est un et
indivisible
c'est là qu'il a été mis en place et
souhaitée par nicolas sarkozy pour être
un grand projet unique qui permet à
l'ensemble de la région parisienne de
devenir une région capitale dont chaque
élément est indissociable des autres et
sacrifier une partie de ces éléments
c'est sacrifier le projet en lui-même et
ne pas permettre à paris de devenir
cette région extrêmement dynamique dont
la france a besoin
une autre réaction celle du medef
ile-de-france satisfaction concernant le
financement pour le syndicat des patrons
pas de nouvelles taxes sur les
entreprises mais un regret en revanche
de ne pas voir naître un partenariat
public privé pour les réalisations
et puis surtout que la desserte du
plateau de saclay soit insuffisante pour
le faire rivaliser à l'avenir avec les
autres pôles d'innovation mondiaux c'est
le point de vue du medef ile-de-france
qui était un communiqué il ya quelques
instants nous restons dans le domaine du
transport avant de penser au grand paris
express les usagers de la ligne la
verrière la défense aimerait pouvoir
tout simplement reprendre le train
reprendre leurs lignes le trafic est
suspendu depuis le 24 février en raison
d'un incendie à la direction semble les
avoir entendu une réouverture partielle
est d'ores et déjà annoncée pour demain
bonne nouvelle pour les usagers de la
ligne u celle reliant la verrière à la
défense une reprise somme toute
partielle du trafic est prévue ce jeudi
7 mars à raison d'un train par demi
heure aux heures de pointe et un train
par heure aux heures dites creuses
à noter que la liaison sera direct entre
les gares de saint cloud et de la
défense sans desserte des gares du val
d'or de suresnes mont valérien et de
puteaux première partie de la reprise
normale du trafic le samedi 9 et le
dimanche 10 mars reprise totale du
trafic jeudi 14 mars
d'ici là et compte tenu du nombre réduit
de trains rétablie sur la ligne où les
voyageurs sont invités à continuer à
emprunter les itinéraires alternatifs
ligne c du rer ou ligne rennes jusqu'à
montparnasse pour rappel le trafic est
interrompu depuis le 24 février à la
suite d'un incendie au poste de
signalisation en gare de sèvres-ville
d'avray la destruction du poste avait
occasionné la perte des systèmes de
signalisation sur près de 3 km de voies